hello i'm hannah k and welcome to this
intelligent squared event
with suzanne simard on the hidden
language of trees
there are various ways in which you can
get involved you can ask questions
join in the audience chat and tweet us
using the
iq2 and in the sidebar on the right hand
of your screen you'll see a link
where you can get a discounted copy of
suzanne's fascinating new book
which is called finding the mother tree
uncovering the wisdom and intelligence
of the forest
it's a really fascinating read and it's
also just been announced that it's going
to be turned into a hollywood movie
and i'm sure we'll be hearing more about
that soon
quick look ahead before we start
tomorrow night we have
the turkish author and activist
sharing her vision of optimism about the
post-pandemic future
then coming up over the next few weeks
our speakers include carla rivelli
philip pullman salman julian tet
and kathleen turner and we're launching
new events all the time so look out for
our forthcoming mailers
but now back to tonight i'm really
delighted to hand over to our chair
he is one of this country's leading
environmentalists
and amongst the many books that he's
written he's written one on the
rainforest
so very relevant to tonight's topic he
is
tony juniper well thank you very much
indeed hannah an absolute pleasure to be
here this
evening and to welcome you all to this
in intelligent squared event with
suzanne
simard now suzanne is professor of
forest ecology at the university of
british columbia
faculty of forestry she was raised in
the monash mountains of british columbia
and has earned a global reputation for
her research on tree connectivity and
communication
and its impact on the health and the
biodiversity of forests her new book
uh called finding the mother tree
uncovering the wisdom and intelligence
of the forest
uh is uh a groundbreaking piece i have
to say i've written about some of these
themes
uh myself but only ever been able to
skim over
some of the broad findings but in that
book we find the research and the story
behind it and i'm looking forward to the
conversation a great deal
so what we're going to be doing this
evening uh is to run the the discussion
for an hour uh the first 30 minutes
suzanne and i will
have a conversation and pick up various
points and then during the second half
we'll be taking your questions uh so you
can start asking them right away if you
click on that q
a button down there on the bottom right
of your screen and type in your question
then press
send then it will appear and we'll be
able to pick them up as we we get into
the
second part of the conversation um
if you uh did want to tweet uh please
use the hashtag
q iq2 iq2
and as we go along then please don't
forget that the question box
is open um so um suzanne
uh i've been working uh as an ecologist
in in different ways for
a great many years and you know one of
the themes that inevitably comes into
any discussion about ecology
is this interconnected nature of nature
and how all of the different elements of
the natural world
are connected with one another what your
book does
is take that theme to a whole new level
in understanding this connectivity that
we can't even
see unless we take the kind of forensic
approaches you've been taking as a
scientist
when did you first begin to become aware
of this phenomenon that's going on
underneath the forest floor
well i grew up in the inland rainforests
of british columbia um
and so you know i i'm a person of the
woods
i um i think in my you know my family
were forest families
my grandfather and great grandfather
were horse loggers
and so this is how i grew up i grew up
in this place
and my grandfather especially was very
aware
um very meticulous about how he logged
which
meant taking out one or two trees in in
his logging
with horses and and so he was always
teaching us about
about the importance of the connection
in the forest and not to to disrupt that
un unnecessary and only only to take
what we needed
and and so that you know that experience
as a child
growing up with that philosophy um
of course bled into my own worldview of
forests and i eventually became a
forester
but when i stepped into forestry i
realized that that the whole practice
was about disconnecting the forest
about isolating the parts and treating
the trees as separate from
all the other creatures in fact favoring
them at the expense of
pretty much all else all other species
and
um and so that got me onto this track of
trying to understand
what the dangers of this were of this
very disconnected view
and management of forests um and then
uncovering you know the consequences of
it
and in so doing you know i discovered of
course more and more
about connection um literally that trees
are connected below ground
yeah now you're really um getting me
um thinking about some of the key themes
that now
run through the way we look at nature
and i guess one of the
points you touched on there is the
extent to which we
have become used now to looking at
forests as natural resources
rather than some intricate
self-sustaining system with incredible
complexity in it
and that approach which arises from you
know the the
need to get fiber and wood to make paper
and timber
it seems to have blinded us completely
to this reality and
you know forestry today um how would you
um characterize the way in which that
subject is taught
because what your grandfather was doing
sustainable logging horse
uh horse extraction um that now is
is very much the exception isn't it
rather than the rule
in terms of how that particular
particular industry works
well so when i went through forestry
school which was in the 1980s and then
in graduate school in the 90s um well i
was taught that the forest
you know that you know the trees compete
with each other that we need to isolate
them
and you know favor them um get rid of
the other plants
even the animals and insects that are
you know feeding on them
basically disrupting the whole
successional process and the food webs
that make that drive all the cycles in
the forest
um but now you know i'm a professor of
forestry and i teach
my students about connection um and that
that it's important to
to keep those connections in place and
to move to a more you know
you know uh what would i say it's more
of a
natural disturbance ecology based
approach
um but of course there's a whole legacy
that has built up over the last
half century of of treating the forest
as a commodity based
uh uh resource as you as you called it
which has you know when you get on that
track and start managing forests in that
way
because forests are long lived uh and
trees are long-lived creatures
and also that the industry starts to
build on itself right it becomes
entrenched in its own
methods its own policies and there's a
lot of money involved in it that
changing that even though you know i
teach philosophically
and i think forest forest ecology
professors around the world are probably
teaching more
uh philosophically about connection as
well it's hard to change the industry
midstream or
you know at any point um so it's gonna
take
you know it's gonna take a lot of effort
to to change
uh the force industry but in doing that
you have to change people's minds and
habits and and
uh and also educate everybody about
about connection
in forests and what makes them work
maybe we'll come back to some of those
themes uh
in a moment suzanne but maybe just
return to to some of the core research
and
what you've discovered in terms of how a
forest is working at this different
level
which is now only just becoming apparent
am i right
in in thinking that the parallels have
been made with the brain
in terms of how the forest is working
with these multiple connections
yes well certainly neural networks i've
um and i've
uh used the example of the brain because
it's another kind of biological neural
network and so
so let me explain what what i mean by
that so
you know what i have studied are these
mycorrhizal fungal networks that link
trees below ground
and in fact you know these mycorrhizal
well mycorrhizae is
literally means fungus root it's a it's
a mutualistic generally mutualistic
symbiotic relationship between trees and
and fungi um all trees all over the
world form these
these relationships it's it's crucial
for their fitness for them to actually
produce
seed and reproduce um and for the fungus
it's essential because they can't
photosynthesize so they work together
the fungus gathers nutrients and water
from the soil
and the tree provides photosynthetic as
an energy source
and so what i found what really built on
the work done by david reed in the
united kingdom
where he showed in laboratories that
that pine seedlings could be
connected by these fungal fungal species
below ground
and i took that to the next level and
asked well does this actually happen in
real forests
and what do they do and in finding that
these connections are
ubiquitous you know in all the forests
that we've looked at in all labs all
over the world
um and then finding that their conduits
really for
movement of resources that the community
shifts resource uh distribution based on
the needs of the community and and this
um so it follows these gradients that
are
that trees perceive um and they respond
to them
and and so this actually uh enhances
diversity of the forest it enhances
can as a fundamental to the connection
of forests
and of course you know of course
ecologists long have known about
relationships and forests that's what
they study
but this actually showed a physical
connection that really turned
upside down how we started to view
forests
it's incredible isn't it and i remember
from my research for for the rainforest
book
really skimming this area compared with
the depth that you've gone into
uh reading uh some uh some science that
was making a link also with the trees
communicating with one another
um when one was under pest attack uh
communicating with chemical signals and
then the trees
nearby responding by raising their own
chemical defenses
is that something that you've uh
encountered as well
yes yes actually um i worked with a
scientist
dr yanyan song who is from china and she
worked with tomato plants and found this
phenomenon
between tomato plants and so she came
over as the postdoc and worked with me
in our rain forest in bc
and we found you know we did these
experiments
and found the same thing as happening
among trees and we were actually working
with
trees of different species so she worked
with tomato plants they're all the same
species
linked together in a network i was
working with douglas fir
and ponderosa pine and the reason i was
interested in these two species
because as climate is changing douglas
fir is receding along the drier margins
of its distribution so
you know it's it interfaces with
grasslands and
and as climate as the temperatures warm
it's moving
upward it will move upward in in
elevation and northward
and be in in theory be replaced by
ponderosa pine
and so i was interested in whether as
douglas fir was
basically receding from these margins
and
and ponderosa pine taking over whether
there was this communication
uh between the two species and found
that douglas fir was
warning actually ponderosa pine about
injury
and uh herbivores in the environment
that were causing them to die back
and so it is an incredibly important
phenomenon
in the adaptability of forests as as
climate changes
yeah so this is fundamental to the
health of the entire system then isn't
it as you're describing because if the
trees
are supplying uh being supplied with
nutrients by the fungi and also
having these wider environmental
warnings being flagged
what's the implication uh for the future
of forests
in going down this route of industrial
forestry with monoculture
crops of trees single age as you're
describing being
favored at the expense of everything
else do we have any sense of the future
of forestry even
from this research that's those are all
really good questions so
the the first question is you know is
what are the implications of
modern forestry and you know there are
huge implications you know for one the
old growth forest that
i grew up around um and there are these
old forests that
you know have they can be thousands of
years old um
um they occur in the amazon they occur
along the west coast of north america
they occur across the boreal forest
they occur in temperate forests and
these forests can be like i said
hundreds to thousands of years old
which means that that over that period
of time
there's a number of things that have
happened one is climate has
changed um you know it goes up and down
and
that change uh trees adapt to those
changes and they record it in the dna
that's
in their seeds and so they actually hold
a repository of adaptability in their
seeds
if we get rid of these old trees then
that you know that
seed source basically disappears the
other thing that
old forests do is they they store a huge
amount of carbon
um and in the old growth forest it's
basically been accumulating for
centuries and um when we cut those
forests down
pretty much automatically you know the
the removal of the trees themselves most
of that carbon over two-thirds of it
is pretty much just dissipates into the
atmosphere immediately
because it's converted to these
short-term products like toilet paper
and so on
um and so you know and then
the below-ground community also which
holds half the carbon it's also
enhances decomposition processes and so
there's
there is an enormous loss of carbon you
know over half
um by the time all is said and done in
the in the system has started to decline
and decompose
and then replacing these with seedlings
it takes decades if not
you know a century to recover to a
neutral
uh a neutral carbon content and then you
know to become an old growth forest
again
it would take that long again for them
to become store
as much so that's the carbon story
that's a crucial story right it is
harvesting those old growth forests you
can't recapture that carbon
in short periods of time you can't
recapture it with planting trees
within the time period that we have left
to change the course
of climate change and of course the
biodiversity is another
question too like they are the homes of
80
of our biodiversity terrestrial and so
losing that biodiversity is also
super a super critical loss absolutely
and i remember some analysis that's come
from various
uh scientists who've mapped carbon and
also biodiversity
and found that they're in the same place
that the big stocks
remaining biological carbon and the um
biological diversity are in the same
spots
and this then of course raises questions
around
you know the policy discourse around
climate change and
you know one of the framings that has
become very prominent here in the uk and
maybe in canada too
as society begins to grapple with
climate change and what to do about it
and yes we're going to have to have
electric cars and we're going to go
to renewable electricity but a very big
emphasis on tree
planting and i i find this framing
fascinating because as an ecologist it
seems to me
that first priority is to conserve the
remaining forest
rather than to go for tree planting and
then the second priority
i would describe as expanding woodland
rather than tree planting and you know
most ears those two things might sound
like exactly the same thing
uh but what you're describing is is
something which is rather different
and uh one wonders uh what can be done
to shift that emphasis in the discussion
because
you know some of it evidently is being
driven by some of the commercial
interests and the extent to which
a natural woodland has got little
immediate value in the market
whereas a tree crop ultimately will be
generating a return
in terms of its um timber sale ability
what do we need to do i wonder to move
the discussion on um
is it simply a question of of
challenging some of these business
models or is it a more profound
shift of consciousness that's needed
probably both i'm thinking
i think both i mean certainly the
business model
is based on you know it's a growth model
and
it's you know and it values forests
based on you know very
rudimentary products you know in british
columbia and canada it's
two by fours pulp and paper um and
that's a very low value assigned to the
forest when it's actually our
life-sustaining
support systems right as you mentioned
early in our interview
i mean it these so we really need to
value our forest based on the the
the true you know importance of them to
our lives you know
you know their ability to clean water
clean air
uh store carbon biodiversity how do you
put a price on that
it yeah we haven't we haven't
taken that difficult step to do that but
we have to uh
and once we do that then we'll you know
we'll start to say oh these old growth
fours are way more valuable standing up
than on a on a you know on a train with
that is full of two by fours and so
that's a fundamental shift we have to
make we absolutely have to
put a price on carbon and hopefully
biodiversity and water and
and air and all that um we haven't had
to
so far because you know it's we've it
seems like we've had
endless resources of of forest and but
you know where i
live which is sort of like the last
frontier british
has in my lifetime has turned from a
province of old growth forest to a
province
of clear cuts because we haven't valued
these these forests properly so we have
to do that
how do we do that well people need to
get behind their governments
and force their governments to do it and
in order for people to get behind it
they need to
understand the importance of these old
forests
and then woodlands as you said you know
so so conserving and preserving what we
have left is paramount
and then converting or restoring
ecosystems that have been degraded from
native woodlands or forests
back to those native woodlands and
forests is also absolutely crucial
and a woodland you know as we talked
about is very different than a
plantation a woodland
is where you have natural regeneration
or and we can assist that natural
regeneration
but the trees when they get going you
know they're very different than a
planted tree
they they have roots that are complex
they're after resources and so they
they adapt to their soil environment and
they are linked into the
legacies of the past and so they're
really productive they're healthy
they're resilient whereas a plantation
um where we plant
seedlings that are like disconnected
from the ecosystem
you know those are completely different
they're not very diverse they're not
resilient
and um yeah and they're not as valuable
from a
like from a life support system's point
of view
you're reminding me of a field trip i
made uh just two weeks ago
so at the height of the english
springtime to what was
a really very magical place
in east anglia in england a place called
monks wood
it's a national nature reserve and it's
an ancient woodland
but in the early 1960s 1961
a famous british forest ecologist
established a series of so-called
wilderness plots
basically open land some of it grassland
but one
plot was a barley field in 1960
basically the experiment was just to see
what would happen
if you left the barley field next to the
ancient woodland so a seed source and a
source of
animals to move the seeds and i went
there and 60 years on you have ancient
woodland
indicator species coming back in there
and you've got this incredible
uh diverse vibrant system that's come
in what was a wheat field but this is
just so rare
in this country and i think most places
uh because we've become
again used to this idea of tree planting
and the idea of natural regeneration
being something that doesn't quite work
but i was really struck by that and
actually i was even more struck
uh by a 25 year old plot um
so less than half the age of the one
that's now turning into a mature
woodland
um it was just the most incredible riot
of of color of insects of songbird
singing
and you're just suddenly struck that the
value of the woodland is not only the
the mature
closed canopy system you get after 60 70
100 years
but the journey between the open land to
the forest is one
that is just so rich in biodiversity
that successional phase
of course which in nature would be the
result of disturbance
and you know the fact of there being a
storm or an earthquake or a flood and
then the land is cleared and it comes
back
but that beginning of the new forest is
in some ways
for the biodiversity even more important
than what you get after a
longer period and it seems in forestry
um you know the discipline of producing
wooden timber
um these basic facts of life seem to
have um
uh not been embraced in how we look at
this although in some countries maybe
they do
do you have anything in british columbia
that would resemble a natural forestry
cycle you described your grandfather's
horse logging but
is there any modern forestry operation
that's working like that
you know um i wish there was more of it
we do
have you know in some of our dryer
forests there's been a long history of
what we call selective logging
and that that is where you know they
leave old trees
and to provide seed and then they
self-regenerate
under their own canopy they're shade
tolerant trees um and they
they look pretty natural and of course
we do have old growth
uh reserves and preserves and protected
areas
um but most of our preserves are you
know in parks
are in areas where people go mountain
climbing or you know
hiking in in the high elevations and
they don't have the big
valuable old trees and so we really
struggle with that as well
and you know our forestry practice is to
when
when you know cutting happens and it's
generally clear-cutting maybe
leaving in the odd tree there um those
are planted they're all planted back
and we basically have gotten on to what
you're talking about which is
you know they plant them quickly so they
can grow a forest quickly so they can
cut it down quickly um
and those fours are very different than
the naturally regenerated forest as you
say
i mean we even go in forestry so far as
to take out the native plants that are
those early successional
plants right that and short-circuiting
natural selection
so that we create these like conifer
plantations that really you know
you've lost that such a crucial period
i call it like the healing period of the
forest where after a disturbance
you have these plants come in because
they have a role to play right exactly
to take up nutrients to heal the soil
and
create a nice foundation for a nice
diverse forest coming up
exactly and i saw in those 25 year old
wilderness plots at monks wood the
dynamic
between the forest trees that ultimately
dominate the system
and the successional thorny scrub of
brambles and hawthorn
and the acorns are planted in there by
the birds
and it's the brambles and the thickets
of thorns that enable the trees to get
through
without being eaten by the deer they're
kind of protected by a nursery of these
thorny
shrubs and it's an incredible thing to
see but you so rarely see it because
everything is so massively managed
and the human intervention is always uh
so strong certainly in this country but
hopefully as we go forward
uh we'll be able to harness more of
these natural processes to bring back
the biodiversity
but also as you say to catch the carbon
now i wonder
and you you've evidently been working in
this field for for a long time suzanne
whether
you know you feel as though we may be
reaching some kind of
public consciousness tipping point on
all of this
because you know we we've had campaigns
on on forests and deforestation since
the 1970s and i
i was personally involved from 1990
working at friends of the earth on the
tropical forest campaign but still we
have these
areas of forest being cut down and set
on fire and clear felled
what do you think is the near-term
future are we going to be able to turn
that back have we reached a tipping
point
well we do need to change our practices
in our view our worldview of forests
um instead of exploiting them we need to
be protecting them and and
fostering their regeneration and i i
agree with you on natural regeneration
and we can combine
natural regeneration with planting to
bootstrap these ecosystems back into a
productive state but
um in british columbia where i live it's
gotten so critical
you know this tip approaching this
tipping point that we actually only have
you know eight percent of our productive
old growth forest left
the rest have been clear-cut on
vancouver island southern vancouver
only three percent left and right now um
we actually have huge protests going on
at a place called fairy creek which is
the last untouched headwaters of old
world forest
on vancouver island which is one of the
most productive forest areas in the
world
and here we are you know we have
students and protesters you know
basically
putting their lives on the line yes um
you know to fight the zeal to cut down
those last
few trees in the name of what you know
to create
to make a few bucks like it's just it
doesn't add up right we're far better
off to leave those forests standing
and to support these protesters so that
we that we do make this
make the government make the shift right
that we value these wars
more for their their biodiversity and
carbon storage and all that
instead of you know to make a few bucks
for the short term
yeah indeed and this is then where your
point about the um
the uh the ecosystem services and the
valuation
and and to help people understand that
you know
there is a far bigger actual economic
value of the forest
standing up yes being cut down worth
more alive than dead is a
is a phrase that the prince of wales has
used to talk about this and trying to
get that across
now suzanne just before we open up into
um the the
the questions uh from the uh people
tuning in on
zoom can you just take us in a little
bit into the
actual mechanism of how this story is
unfolding underground and how
uh the the trees are actually
communicating with one another is it
literally like a nervous system
um you think of like neurotransmitters
and synapses is it like
that yeah it's got it certainly has
parallels to that and
um so i call it a biological neural
network because when we map
the network in the forest we found that
it has that pattern
where you have a few you know nodes that
are really big and highly connected
and then a bunch of satellites and those
will be the you know smaller trees
connected by these fungal networks and
when we graph
when we use statistical graph theory to
analyze that it comes out as a as a
neural network which are quite
complex with highly connected nodes and
less connected ones
with linkages between them and what we
found is that
um these linkages they're they're
conduits for transmission of
resources ins that have certain
chemistry to them
and one of the main uh
uh resources that moves through or the
compounds that moves through the network
is
is glutamate which is the same as one of
our own neural
neurotransmitters is is glutamate and we
also know
like plants actually have serotonin in
them as well
um and so the combination of of the
pattern of the network that it's a
neural network that there
are neuro you know these glutamate
compounds that move through them
and also we have synapses in in these
networks below ground as well between
the fungus
and the plant root where this
transmission or this exchange goes on
and so there's a lot of parallels
and you know i think that the reason
there are parallels is that these
complex networks these
neural networks um they work right
they're highly evolved
across many different kinds of systems
not just in our own brains
and of course what i'm describing here
are not brains in the soil
soil there are patterns there are
patterns that have
parallel functions and and structures um
but anyway these neural networks are
highly conserved across many systems
um because they work they're efficient
at moving information around they're
resilient
in fact in our own built systems
human systems we we use we mimic those
systems
right because they're so efficient like
our transportation systems
the subway system you know you'll have a
few you know
uh subway stations that are highly you
know that are the key hubs and then all
these other
smaller ones that go to the smaller area
rural areas around it so
those neural networks we see them
ubiquitously across our social and built
environments as well
because they work so well yeah
just thinking of deforestation in that
subject of you know the continuing loss
of forests
do we have any sense of of how recovery
occurs
so the natural regeneration piece we
talked about a bit would we expect the
fungal
networks to be recovering in there
presumably yes yeah
yes they will i mean as long as there
are plants um and they're
photosynthesizing and especially if you
allow those
trees and plants to to carry out their
full life cycle
you know that the the fungal community
actually has a succession to it as well
right so after a disturbance immediately
or if you're trying to restore a
grassland
to a forest or a woodland then that
fungal network will be quite simple and
maybe even different than it would be
with a woodland and you might have to
do some remediation of the network but
once the trees get going and
aging that the the fungal network
becomes more complex
you get you know these i call them sort
of old growth fungal species come on and
they have
different niches different
functionalities and then the system
works better and better and better as
the woodland gets older and older
right indeed and that aging process
maybe is something that we kind of
don't pay too much attention to as we're
obsessed with tree planting how many
millions of trees can we plant how many
hectares
recognizing that the stuff that we've
got that's most valuable in this country
have the term ancient woodland
uh which is by definition a woodland
that's older than 1600 so
420 years and you know we
value those particularly because of the
biodiversity and everything else
uh but one wonders how much we think
about 400 year type time scales as we're
adopting tree planting targets one for
the policy makers
susan let's let's delve into a few of
the questions now so one has come
through here
um on the question of forest fires and
what extent
uh we should be um trying to prevent
them and put them out
and you know that's quite topical isn't
it given you know the headlines over the
last couple of years with massive forest
fires
in some geographies um with actually you
know
um uh president trump not the world's
greatest environmentalist i think it's
fair to say
um suggesting that you know this is
because we haven't cut enough trees down
i mean
obviously a lot of complexity in all of
this and also depending on the geography
but what should we do about fires should
we worry too much
well fires you know most of our fires at
least in the northern hemisphere are
fire regenerated forests
sorry most of our forests are fire
regenerated forest that means that
they've adapted to fire
and that they depend on fire to
rejuvenate the forest
um and so you know it's it's to our you
know benefit to
to you know uh keep those natural fire
regimes in place as much as we can what
we've done in north america is we've
suppressed fire and i'm i'm sure that's
probably the case in europe as well
um and uh so that we can you know
save these forests in in the case of
north america so that we can cut them
down later and
benefit ourselves um and but in
suppressing fire we've actually made the
situation worse right
because fuels build up and uh and then
the forests are more vulnerable and as
climate changes
and the temperatures go up when you have
you know high fuel loads and high
temperatures all you need is a spark
and you can have these huge mega fires
and so that's what we're kind of dealing
with down here um
so the extent and the severity of fires
are actually increasing as climate is
changing
but you know i think that it doesn't
mean that we should be excluding fire
even more it means that we need to re we
should be reintroducing fire to
reinvigorate these communities
because these forests are adapted they
need fire to
to do well um and because we have our
population our human population
has grown so much of course that's going
to have to get controlled so that
um in a sense have controlled wild burns
if you
want to call it that um so that they
don't escape into our communities and
harm people but it can be done you know
we can be successful at that we just
have to get a little smarter
and practice it more yeah indeed
um yes and uh something um that is
evidently not going to go away as the
climate changes
um suzanne um actually one john here is
picking up the question
um how do you define a mother tree how
does this work in a forest which is
probably a good question given the name
of the book
so yeah i mean we i came up where we
came up with that name
through a series of experiments um but
the main thing is
well just simply they're the biggest
oldest trees in the forest
um and the reason that that they are the
you know the mother trees is because
their root systems are vast they have
um and if they're old they have like
these fungal networks that are
you know ancient or older mycorrhizal
fungi that do
all these amazing uh things in different
niches in the soil
um and so they're they're extensive
they're diverse
and they actually through our
experiments we found that these networks
nurture the regeneration of the new
seedlings coming up
um so these old trees will provide the
network in which the natural
regeneration
establishes and then the old trees will
transmit
resources like water and carbon and
nitrogen
um and defense signals and they even
transmit information about the wrecking
about the relatedness of of these old
trees to the seedlings
and um and that you know that process is
essential
to regeneration of a healthy forest so
yes
that's what a mother tree is yeah and
that's an incredible uh
incredible insight that's come from what
you've been investigating
um do those mother trees um favor their
own species or or are they assisting
everything that's growing around them
you know that it's a community a
community of many species and they're
all
linked together and there is this fluid
transmission between all the different
species
and so you know certainly you know when
we think of evolution in this very
narrow sense it's about survival of the
fittest and individual species
and how competition is such an important
part of that well it turns out
collaboration is also an important part
of that as well
and from a community point of view you
know trees
and plants and animals they grow in
mixed communities they don't grow
all by themselves as a single species as
a population
and so um you know this trend you know
these linkages actually happen between
species these below ground linkages
and there's a transmission of resources
from one species to another
i in fact my first experiments were with
birch and fur
and that they transmit carbon back and
forth between them
and you know this actually helped keep
the community diverse
and resistant to the diseases that were
occurring in in the soil in my
forest type right so they're benefiting
um
so you could explain this in kind of
darwinian evolutionary terms
in the sense of the individual is
helping the community to help the
individual
exactly that's exactly right yeah cool
well something definitely been out there
for human societies i i guess that's
some kind of um
arboreal socialism going on there
so well it's a it's a complex system
right it's yeah
it's neither socialism or capitalism
it's it's
both right it is you know they compete
but they collaborate they have these
sophisticated ways of
interacting and communicating and that
that's what makes it
makes it a a diverse and resilient
society right it's like if we were all
we ever did as humans was compete
against each other
and you know we get dominant individuals
well society would collapse
right we need to have these sharing uh
you know collaborative work
and people have their different niches
right they have their different areas of
expertise
and we work together to create this
productive community it's the same in a
forest
yeah indeed and the diversity is part of
its strength
in that yes it is part of its resilience
yes it is and there's lots of studies to
show that that as diversity goes up that
productivity goes up and and resilience
goes up or its ability to resist
infections and invasions and so on
yeah so so the um the the the the mono
culture which is dominated is is perhaps
um
something that we need to bring into
many of these discussions and actually
the same
of course prevails in agriculture not
only foreign
yeah and i think that that's such
economically driven right if we
i know in british columbia you know we
thought oh we made so much money off of
douglas or we're just going to grow
douglas fir
like what were you thinking really but
we tried you know and
it didn't work very well because all you
know we started getting our malaria root
disease and the linus root disease and
western spruce budworm and it's like
well that didn't work because it's we
took this
diverse community and tried to reduce it
down to a commodity
and that commodity cannot be grown by
itself alone
and it's interesting you know even today
you know we're talking about you know
how do we manage our land base well we
should zone off
you know these plantations and have
zones of plantations then we can have a
zone of natural forest
we have a zone of wild forest but those
plantations if we think that they're
going to be the most productive
places where we're going to make a lot
of money i think we you know we're going
to be fooled by
that because yeah these ecosystems even
if we're
putting in fertilizers and water and
irrigating them and pruning them
they still are very vulnerable if you
grow them as single species
yeah right and events in the real world
um underline that fact so just on this
question of of commodities suzanne and
um you know driven by consumption and
the market and our particular form of
economics
karen doherty has a question here she
says
there have been well-known campaigns
around reducing the consumption of
products linked with
tropical deforestation for example beef
and palm oil
do we need she asks to reduce
consumption of products produced from
conifer plantations
if we want natural forests to regenerate
so
yeah that's that's an interesting one
yeah it's a really good question and i
think that we can be way smarter about
our consumption
you know i think we're consuming is that
we have an endless resource right
there's a lot of um
you know basically over consumption and
and i think you know if we we can use
alternative uh materials um
but we can also just use less right do
we need to keep
you know re or building huge houses in
north america for example that
that people you'll have two people
living in these huge
mansions or yeah they don't need all
that they can live with smaller houses
this
the houses back in the 40s were like a
tenth
i don't know maybe that's an
exaggeration a fraction of the size of
what they are now
so we we need to be you know a little
more humble i think in our our
consumption
um we do yeah yeah we do
and here's another point um you know in
in british columbia right now we're
having a big debate because we're
turning some of our boreal forests and
temperate forests
into wood pellets and sending the wood
pellets to the uk so that the uk
you know europeans can burn these wood
pellets in their stoves as a
an alternative to fossil fuels well
actually that is
more of an environmental disaster than
burning the fossil fuels themselves
because we're cutting down these boreal
forests
to create pellets and that's resulting
in loss of biodiversity and huge
emissions of carbon
uh to the atmosphere while we're saving
a few
you know btus from not burning fossil
fuels in europe it doesn't make it
doesn't add up
right we need to do the right kinds of
calculations we gotta
the economics have to be in place that
the the the models have to be correct so
that we
really truly understand the cost of this
kind of practice
um you know you might be solving a
practice over
in europe but we're leaking really badly
over in north america
carbon because we're trying to fuel or
feed this market that is not very well
thought out okay and so um
uh lilly lajevardi
i'm so sorry lily if i've mispronounced
your name but a question
um very much linked to these points
suzanne we're touching on here whether
it's biomass or timber
or fiber how do you see the future of
commercial forestry what is a model you
think we can reasonably transition to
and actually that's a key question isn't
it because it links to the market it
links to consumption and
the kind of business models that would
um be there in the future if we're going
to solve these problems and i
yeah i guess well one element of that
would be you know the extent to which
we're valuing
all of the non-resource uh elements the
carbon the water the biodiversity
everything else
how do you see that and the future of
commercial forestry
yeah so so um yeah
valuing forest ecosystems properly is
essential
um and once we you know but we don't
even need to put that in place quite yet
we can automatically right away just
stop cutting down old growth forest
because we can't environmentally afford
to do this anywhere in our globe right
the feedback loops to climate change are
huge and we
you know we understand enough for that
we know it's not a good thing to do
and so then we can shift our focus if we
you know we still need wood
we can shift our focus to second growth
forest so or a third growth or
you know places that have already been
harvested because we've already lost the
carbon stocks or a good part of them
and so you know let's focus on where the
losses have already occurred
and in those forests we can recut we can
help them recover
too and the way we can do that is
leaving old
you know the older trees in place you
can still take out the smaller trees
around them
um but selectively uh taking out the
smaller trees and leaving the big old
trees
to bootstrap the natural regeneration uh
and and you know add in some planting
too if necessary
um to make a healthy ecosystem but
that's diverse
you know that we're actually fostering
the diversity by leaving these old
legacies behind
but but the key point here is leave the
old forests as much as we have left as
much as we can
now and focus our cutting on these
second growth forest or
you know already degraded forests and
then within those
you know work to enhance them like
leaving the old trees introducing
you know old growth elements into them
we can do that you know we have enough
knowledge to do that
yes we have the knowledge um i guess the
challenges is creating the business
model and the
the culture in forestry isn't it to be
wanting to adopt those those methods
one of the things i've been struck by um
in this part of the world is
you know different cultures that exist
in forestry in different countries and
you know sometimes traveling in france
i'm struck by the difference of the
woodlands there
where for centuries they've had an
approach
which is in large part based upon
natural regeneration so quite a lot of
husbanding and uh pruning and um
you know uh thinning uh but basically
the dynamics of the forest
uh to to a large extent left intact
compared with replacing the old growth
forest and
putting a a monoculture of of pine trees
or conifers on top of it which is what
happened across much of england uh over
the decades and we're now in the process
of trying
to reverse that uh in some cases at
least
now actually just on that question of
industrialization and the industrialized
mindset
uh monia or monica you might misspelt
your name there monia or monica
thank you for the question which is has
genetic modification
reached the forests do we do we have gmo
tree crops coming yet you know i don't
know a lot about gmo tree crops i know
that people are working on it they have
been for
decades and um there certainly are you
know plantations i know in the south
the south east united states they grow
gmo
cottonwoods for example to produce fiber
for toilet paper and so on
so i know those do exist but in that in
forestry practices in canada
and where i'm from they don't do gmo
trees but they do
uh tree breeding and tree breeding is
taking
you know natural genetic diversity and
breeding for for faster growing
trees and i think there is a place
for this and um but you know i think
most importantly where genetics is
essential that we
um you know as climate changes the
velocity of climate change is very rapid
it's much more rapid than trees can
naturally
adapt and uh and evolve and it's a lot
faster than
they are able to migrate as well so
trees the only other alternative they
have if they can't migrate if they can't
adapt
they'll die and so um it's you know as
we know that climate is changing quickly
we're gonna have to help trees migrate
right so that they can
so we can keep forests on the ground so
they can continue to keep carbon in the
ground
and carbon you know being sequestered
and biodiversity so it's going to be our
job as human beings to help these
forests
uh to to have you know a mix of
naturally regenerated
seedlings that are going to provide a
scaffolding for these migrants
that we can move them into and then they
can work together to create a
a viable ecosystem um okay so in that
sense so that's not gmo though
that is just tree breeding and then
moving assisting the migration that's
quite two different
quite two two quite different things
absolutely
um so there's a perhaps a related
question here from simon wicker
so simon's asking with tree diseases
such as ash dieback i don't if you come
across that it's affecting
um ash trees um fraxiness if you know
that genius it's um
probably got it in north america could
the network provide a solution to these
diseases naturally
if we leave the trees standing and allow
them to produce seed with resilience to
the diseases
rather than cutting them down when they
show signs of sickness and that's
actually
a really a very live question here at
the moment as that disease now is is
rampaging across the country with many
sick ash trees
um apparent everywhere so um what should
we do about that
well the you know the first thing is
that the reason that
one of the reasons that we have the
problem in the first place is that we've
planted
you know monocultures of ash trees or
along boulevards
where we don't have mixes of species and
so when you have
a single species crowded together and
know others
then if you get something like the
emerald ash borer come in it's of course
going to kill those trees
because that's all that's there and so
we so creating a more diverse
forest urban forest or natural forest is
is the ultimate long-term key to this
um but i'll also say that you know we've
done experiments where we show that in
where we've actually stressed trees to
the point where they're dying and i
haven't used the emerald ash borer but
other herbivores
insect herbivores to stress trees and
what we found is that these dying trees
mother trees
actually transmit carbon to their
seedlings especially kin seedlings
around them
to give them a boost to to get onto the
next generation and the
the other thing that we found is that it
changes their
their their defense chemistry as well
there's information that goes to these
seedlings these
especially kin seedlings that they
actually enhance their
defense chemistry we touched on this
earlier but and that
that uh that gets passed on to multiple
generations down the road
and so these old trees are actually
training their offspring
to be more resilient to the to these
herbivores that killed the
the original mother tree in uh at the
beginning
yeah yeah so it does it it's important
to let these natural processes
take place as much as we can instead of
going in like i think our automatic
reaction is let's go in and cut the tree
down
get rid of it burn it or whatever um but
in so doing we're actually
short circuiting that natural process of
teaching the next generation of
of how to survive yeah we take a very
human-centric view of nature don't we um
and yeah and try to make money from it
try to make money from it and then when
it's in trouble feel as though
we have to intervene rather than leave
it alone
um now um on this so with a recurrent
theme here comparing the natural forest
with
um the forestry for for resource
production
a question here from jenny
hoff mulder jenny borgehoff mulder
um are there more pests and diseases in
a crop forest
than there are in a natural forest and
is that similarly affected by climate
change
yeah well yes um i can definitively say
yes because i've studied this and
published about five papers on this
myself
um in for some british columbia's where
we were
looking at plantations actually of
lodgepole pine which i i know that you
plant in europe as well
and douglas fir but this was a study on
lodgepole pine
and we found that there were you know
that there were 50 different damaging
agents that were
causing lethal damage to these
plantations to the point where
only half the trees would be left
standing within a few years
and as the climate was warmer and warmer
which was up
you know we were trying to project what
climate change would do it was worse and
worse and worse
and so these and it's because these
pathogens and insects
they love warm wet conditions right they
reproduce much faster under those
conditions and so then the
infestations are worse um and so yeah
but whereas the natural naturally
regenerated trees even in the same
plantations
that we were looking at if they were
naturally regenerated they weren't
attacked nearly as much they were much
healthier
and you know they had far less incidence
of disease it was more like a natural
forest
and so though ultimately those are the
trees that are going to form the next
forest
not the planted ones because the planted
ones are are on their way out they're
dying right
so it's not it's so it's not only the
resilience of the natural system
actually the resilience of a commercial
operation can be enhanced by fostering
some of these natural processes
and so those young trees that are coming
into the into the plantation forestry
but which are
regenerating on their own yeah is that
the consequence
do you think suzanne of those
relationships underground again
or is it something to do with the
natural selection of the seed
and no it's having enough of the old
trees as a seed source around
so you know seed can disperse you know
with with it most of it within a couple
hundred meters of a living tree
and um and then those seeds will just
naturally come in
and augment whatever you might have
planted there
and and so then of course if as long as
the network is intact if those old trees
exist there then the network will exist
right because it's the old trees are
photosynthesizing and feeding
the network and then then the new
seedlings and the naturally regenerated
seedlings
can tap into that existing network and
and get a head start
um but if you leave it fallow if you
don't if you don't leave some of these
old trees or if you don't
or you cut and you don't plant or you
don't foster
natural regeneration right away that
network will disappear within a within a
couple of years
right okay so um uh
people listening uh don't forget if any
of this is of interest to the point
where you want to share some of the
things you're hearing
do tweet iq2
and we can
help widen some of the discussion in the
twitter sphere
now um is that so camilla redfern
um now this is an interesting one
because we've had a big discussion
uh lately of course around synthetic
meats and fishes and everything else
slightly outside your research area
suzanne but camilla
asks is there any research being carried
out to artificially create
paper fibre substitutes i guess the same
could go for wood couldn't it
in terms of how we might replace these
demands on
forest ecosystems by producing things
somewhere else or with something else
and so the meat
substitute idea obviously is is
inspiring a lot of investment flowing
into that
um slightly different issues but
nonetheless um
one wonders whether there's something
there um i i guess people have talked
about bamboo haven't they and um
the the uh the uh you know
some of the other straw fibres and what
have you that could be made into
wood substitutes yeah and hemp fibers
i mean i'm not an expert in this at all
but um but certainly anything that
creates a fiber you could probably
create paper from and
actually fungal material is being used
for a lot of substitutes for
for wood products even building
materials right
mycelial bricks that you can actually
build a house with even mycelial dresses
and clothing
um and yeah so i think that and also
just you know more
using our wood you know we can still use
wood we can still
um use it more sustainably right we can
yeah substitution is important but also
just
better use of what we we do have as well
exactly
yeah yeah this is this is a big part of
the carbon story that that gets much
less air time the idea of planting a
tree
um is linked with carbon but the end use
of the wood
much less talked about and so you know a
cathedral sitting here in exeter in the
southwest of england
there's a cathedral just across the road
which has got some great big wooden
beams in it that have been in there for
hundreds of years
and so that carbon was captured in the
medieval period and it's still captured
and you know the end uh destination for
wood
um you know compare that with putting
some paper into a landfill or an
incinerator
you know the carbons returned pretty
quickly so that whole life cycle
of how we value wood so alongside the
consumption piece and maybe some of the
substitution issues
is this discussion around how we store
carbon in long-lived products
and it's true i mean i you know one of
the things that horrifies me all the
time is the amount of packaging we use
right do we really need to do that but
that's a huge waste
because we use it once or or paper cups
or
you know we use it it's like that single
use product
those things i think should be outlawed
right because what a what a what a waste
like um you know using more natural
materials to if we need to package
things or
carry something from the grocery store
like carry it in a leaf
or or carry it in your backpack or you
know and just refuse to use those things
i think there are some very smart things
we can do to really can
reduce our consumption of these
short-term products
and then yeah the long-term storage like
building
cathedral that that is a good use even
though you know a standing tree
is actually stores more carbon than than
even a yeah a wooden beam cathedral will
or a wooden
or a log house or yeah the soil carbon
yeah yeah i think that you know the key
though is to try and get rid of these
short-term
uses and single uses of paper because
that's that would
save a lot of force a lot of trees right
off the bat
yeah um yeah the interesting questions
there aren't there
um around the total life cycle of of
wood
compared to whatever else you might use
and so
um you know big discussions around
plastic obviously with all the
awareness around the oceans uh filling
up with with waste and
uh you know a natural alternative to
plastic is
is paper and you know i know a lot of
architects lately who have been thinking
about the carbon story
um thinking about how you can move away
from steel and concrete and again
structural wood
uh is an alternative there so um yeah
quite a lot of
uh analysis i guess required to
understand the full picture
yeah recognizing that people probably um
you know
will want to continue building buildings
into the future
yeah and we do have we do have brilliant
modeling right we do have
brilliant ways to look at this and
analyze it properly and
we we need to do it we need to really
take a whole
whole system approach to analyzing the
products and their uses and
value suzanne we've covered the most
incredible um amount of ground
uh we've gone from natural regeneration
to thinking about planting we've talked
about consumption of raw materials
we've talked about carbon and
biodiversity the culture of forestry
and much in between but i fear we're out
of time which um
is an incredibly quick hour and so
i see i see hannah is back there hannah
i'm gonna hand over
to you in just a second um but can i
just say
thank you suzanne for being with us this
evening and for sharing such a great
deal
of wisdom at so many levels and thank
you everybody
for joining the intelligence squared
event this evening and don't forget you
can get a copy
of finding the mother tree
i believe there's a little tab there you
can click is that right hannah
and people can order the book there
i do hope you've all enjoyed this
conversation as
much as i have suzanne thank you for
your
incredible contribution to a theme which
um i am absolutely certain that we've
not heard the last of and
having heard that this is now going to
be made into a hollywood film i think
maybe this is just the beginning and you
know the insight and the wisdom that
comes from ecology and translating that
into stories that people can understand
possibly is the most important job on
planet earth
uh in the early 21st century so thank
you for all your contributions and
we'll look forward to learning more of
your work as we go along hannah back to
you
thank you tony those are really great
questions thank you
thank you um tony and suzanne that was
such a fascinating conversation as tony
says let's hope this is just the
beginning
i think with this conversation with the
book and obviously the film
um this message is going to get out
there and i can see
from all the chat and the questions that
our audience have really
enjoyed this conversation so for me and
all of us at intelligent squared
thank you very much for watching and see
you again soon